mr president why are you going to walter
reed
going out to visit some of the soldiers
and sailors that are
wounded and look at the vaccination
procedure i've been at wall to read a
lot
i spent almost six months there myself
as a patient
and uh in addition to that as vice
president
every single christmas we spent all
christmas day
walter reed these kids are amazing and
thank god there's not as many people to
visit
all the people i'm seeing today who are
being treated
or for them amputees are people who uh
in fact are retired and but they're
they're real heroes and then we're gonna
go see the vaccination distribution
so they're uh i uh
i spent a lot of time at walter reed
they're
great americans they're great people
nice to see you any progress on your
covent bill
i'm sorry please support passing covet
release through budget reconciliation
i support passing cobra relief with
support from republicans if we can get
it
but the cover relief has to pass there's
no events or buts
chopper talk for president biden and
that brings us back to senator cotton
you heard
what the president said he'd like to
pass kovid relief with republicans but
is prepared to do it without there's
talk
among democrats that they'll do this
through the reconciliation process which
would require just a simple majority
and i'm wondering what happened to the
bipartisan cooperation that there was
between republicans and democrats
late last year to get the last covid
relief bill
done that seems to have evaporated
pretty quickly
john this is another disappointing
development of joe biden after preaching
unity last week immediately empowering
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer to go
along as you said
we passed multiple bills last year
starting in march of the cares act
finishing up in late december
that spent trillions of dollars to give
needed relief to the american people and
fund the record development of so many
vaccines help
schools stay open or get back open as
the case may be
we're happy to work together on a
bipartisan bill that would actually
address those needs that would make sure
that vaccines are getting distributed
that schools are staying open
what we don't want to see is a trillion
dollar bill
multi-trillion dollar bill that is
really just going to fund a lot of
long-standing democratic
priority priorities not things are going
to help us get over the pandemic or deal
with the economic consequences of it i
hope the democrats will
try to cooperate with us so we can pass
a good bill